press freedom is a fundamental right
without the ability to freely report on
events and issues of public interest the
public is left in the dark and unable to
make informed decisions as a person who
spent 438 days in jail just for doing my
job and just for reporting the truth I
think and I believe that press freedom
is a basic right for every single person
there are many sides to one same story
there are many untold stories across the
world freedom of press is being able to
report them listening to as many voices
as possible which otherwise would be
unheard press freedom to me is a
double-edged sword it's the space to
practice my journalism without
interference or pressure or fear of
reprises for what I do but it comes with
a major responsibility to get it right
it's an important day for all of us
without press Freedom general public may
be subject to biased incomplete or even
unverified information it's a privilege
we don't take for granted many of our
colleagues even risk their life in
pursuit of the truth I believe that
serious journalism is more necessary
than ever impartial eyes on the ground
to shed light on the issues that affect
people and communities around the world
freedom of the press means unbiased
fearless and factual reporting from the
ground but a growing number of
autocratic regimes superpower rivalries
and the rise of ultra nationalism are
proving to be a big challenge press
freedom is the ability of journalists to
go on about their work to get the truth
across and the give voice to the people
without getting killed for the mere fact
of being a journalist the same way
Shirin abakler was killed almost a year
ago
[Music]
TV